let's just talk about
not as you said how to take
certain guns away from all people let's
talk about how to keep all guns away
from certain people and those being the
people that we all agree shouldn't have
guns unfortunately a lot of the gun
control that we have right now primarily
disarms the very people who need
protection the most if my research
convinces me of anything
it's people who are most likely victims
of violent crime
overwhelmingly poor blacks who live in
high crime urban areas
who are the ones who benefit the most
from having the option to be able to go
and protect themselves the police are
very important but the police themselves
understand that they virtually always
arrive on the crime scene after the
crimes committed
and having a gun turns out to be by far
the safest course of action
welcome to episode 122 of the michaela
peterson podcast this is another
opposing views episode where i speak
with two people separately who have
opposing views on contentious subjects
this is my favorite format of episode
and one i'll be focusing on more in
upcoming episodes
i spoke with dan gross and dr john r lot
about gun control in america in the
first half i talked to dan gross who did
the stricter gun control side of this
debate
after his brother was very badly wounded
in the 1997 empire state shooting gross
became a gun control activist
he's worked to raise awareness on gun
safety spearheading campaigns that teach
gun owners to mitigate risk
gross is the former president of the
brady campaign to prevent gun violence
and co-founded the center for gun rights
and responsibility in the second half i
spoke with gun rights advocate the
economist and political commentator john
r lott
he's worked for yale the university of
chicago and the u.s department of
justice under trump he's the founder and
former president of the crime prevention
research center john lott has published
op-eds in the wall street journal the
new york times the los angeles times and
more please please remember to keep the
comments civil organizing these episodes
is very tricky and i really love doing
them i think they're so interesting so
let's keep things civil so that more
people will agree to come on
next week's episode is opposing views on
bitcoin i hope you enjoy this episode in
this format if you do please hit
subscribe i usually release episodes
tuesday and friday
but i basically almost died last week
from a combination of strep and rsv a
virus i didn't know existed i'm barely
alive as it is you can probably hear it
in my voice kids are
completely overrated
enjoy your week
[Music]
dan gross welcome to my podcast
thank you
michaela before we get started and i ask
you a bunch of questions can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
yeah i mean what i uh what what what i
do right now is a lot of things but the
reason that we're talking is because of
my
kind of unique and extensive experience
working around guns in the u.s
i got involved with the issue because my
brother was shot in a shooting that
happened on the observation deck of the
empire state building actually in
february of 1997. he was
shot in the head critically injured
miraculously he's he's alive
and so there's a lot to look at in terms
of that cup half full scenario but for
him obviously and for all of us who love
him and care about him it changed the
way we looked at what we do and and our
lives
uh and in my case i at the time i was a
partner at a big ad agency thought i was
living my dream but
uh wound up realizing that there were
things that i could do applying my same
passion for marketing and communicating
uh to this issue of
preventing others from going through
what my family's gone through so i
quit that job in advertising started an
organization that was called pax it
became the center to prevent youth
violence it became the biggest 501 c 3
nonprofit in the country on
on guns
um and uh and then
uh over time as that organization grew
um built a relationship with jim and
sarah brady who were personal heroes of
mine and at one point
they called along with their board and
asked me if i would consider running
their organization down in dc
uh which it was one of those deals where
i said i'll talk to them but it just
doesn't make sense i live in new york
and they're in dc and uh and but lo and
behold after talk to them it was just an
opportunity i couldn't turn down so i
ran the brady campaign for six years
and uh and left a couple years ago um
for a for a variety of reasons but a big
big part of it is i i was
a little bit burnt out focusing just on
this issue uh you know the worst thing
that ever happened to me and dealing
with all the heartbreak um you know on a
daily basis that so many people go
through so uh you know now to answer
your question finally um i do a lot of
consulting um including on including
still on the on the gun issue and i've
started an organization called the
center for gun rights and responsibility
to work with the gun owning community
around the common ground that i've
always been convinced exists
and right now
people are listening to me more than
they they you know especially in the gun
community um than they did when i would
they were able to kind of caricaturize
me as the president of the brady
campaign so
that's what i'm doing a little more than
you bargained for right michaela but uh
that's what uh that's what i do
that's perfect that's perfect so i think
we should start off by you giving maybe
an overview of what your stance on gun
control is and i know that's kind of a
large question but i mean
is it some people should own certain
guns or just a background about what you
believe is right for americans
yeah they're kind of too
first of all what i believe is right for
americans is
almost entirely consistent with what
most americans think is right for for
most americans i'm not trying to
prescribe anything i'm just trying to
find that common ground that i was
talking about and really i think it
essence boils down to to the two things
well one fundamental thing which is
you know we all just want to be safe
and we get so caught up in this
polarizing political debate and
immediately you know pick a team pick a
tribe
based on our political affiliation and
and we don't really
realize all the the common ground that
that that is there and common around
that'll accomplish what we all want
which is to to make all of us safe at
the end of the day um and there are two
fundamental
uh aspects to that that i've always you
know made my quote career on this issue
um folk
focusing on a career where i need more
money i would have an advertising thing
this is a career where the payoff is in
creating some positive change and there
are two two fundamental things
one is
let's just talk about
not as you said how to take
certain guns away from all people let's
talk about how to keep all guns away
from certain people and those being the
people that we all agree shouldn't have
guns uh because when we look at him you
strip away all the rhetoric and all the
anger and
and and and you know that's defined this
quote debate for so long you really
realize we all agree
who probably shouldn't be able to just
waltz into a store and and and buy a gun
most gun stores agree you know people
it's just a it's kind of an obvious
thing when you look at it that way and
then the other half of the equation is
the responsibility that gun owners need
to take
totally compartmentalized from any
political conversation whatsoever about
gun control about
the very real risks associated with
having a gun in the home just like the
real risks if you bring a chainsaw into
your home or a hammer into your home and
you know a piece a piece of electronic
equipment you want to understand what
those risks are and then you want to do
everything that you can to mitigate
those risks unfortunately what's
happened is that because this issue is
so immediately defined as a as an
emotional political debate
gun owners
too often tend to overlook that other
very important part of the conversation
let's talk about the suicide that
happens let's talk about the
unintentional shootings that that happen
but let's talk about him in a way that
gun owners can do reasonable things
without it all curtailing anything
politically they're right on a gun or
you know we've got to go into this with
a with a respect for the fact that
people who own guns
you know
my grandfather and father took me to
yankee games when i was a kid that's
what we did that's how we bonded you
know at this very moment their fathers
and grandfathers taking their kids
hunting and it's by and we have to
respect that this is you know this is
not what this issue is about what i want
is when that father and grandfather take
their kid hunting that they're teaching
that child about firearm safety that
when they get into the home and they
have a teenager there that they're
careful to make sure that that teenager
isn't going to have unsupervised access
to that gun if you know that's what they
deem is is the safest thing to do so
those are the two fundamental things
politically
it to me it's almost entirely about just
keeping guns out of the hands of the
people we all agree shouldn't have them
and then in terms of education and
awareness it's about just starting a
conversation about the very real risks
about a gun in the home and without
trying to take guns away or any gun
control or anything let's educate people
who bring guns into the home about those
risks and what they can do to mitigate
them
okay so that sounds pretty reasonable
thank you uh why why is it that you were
kind of caricatured and like vilified by
certain communities
yeah um i think it's because of
how
the kind of knee-jerk reaction when
it comes to talking about this issue and
you know it's it's
what is what does the media want to show
when it's you know to get eyeballs it's
people want to show a debate um
and
as a result what's happening is you know
i'm saying the same things that i've
always said uh but now people are
listening because i can't be
characterized as
the
president of the brady campaign because
you know now i'm i'm walking a different
walk so
i think it's just a a symptom
um
of of unfortunately the way this issue
has been ingrained into the american
culture as an all or nothing
black and white um metaphorically um
issue rather than you know
there's no incentive for people who run
organizations on both sides of the
issues by the on both sides of the issue
they want to raise money politicians
want to raise their profile they want to
raise money there's no and this is this
issue is not unique in this regard it's
a terrible example of
how you know it's a great example of how
terrible this issue can be um but you
know everybody wants to raise money
everybody wants to raise their profiles
and as a result there's really no
incentive for
like a leading organization on either
side to really genuinely respectfully
put their arm around gun owners and say
like listen we all want the same thing
and that just makes it easy and it kind
of feeds on itself and the result is
like like literally caricatures of me in
you know a leading magazine in the in
the pro
pro gun community with a megaphone with
fire spitting out of it and scared
children in the windows watching me
swing through the city like literally
caricatures but you know that that i can
deal with that's almost fun but it's the
uh what happens as a result of that
which is um it just contributes to this
um this this kind of idea that this is
just a political debate and and as a
result us not listening to each other
yeah well i'm i'm trying to figure out
how to bridge gaps
in these contentious issues so hopefully
this helps um so you talked about
keeping
all guns from the wrong people so how
would you suggest judging people um
figuring out if they're the wrong type
of person yeah and let me start by
saying there's obviously no perfect way
to do that and you're getting into some
genuine conversations about social
justice issues and you know
others other things that that that i
care about deeply but i think it's
important to start by realizing that
right now
those people are defined
um you know there is the the brady bill
that became law
defined and then there was an amendment
to it about domestic abusers the
lautenberg amendment defines those
people convicted
convicted felons
people who've been adjudicated mentally
ill
people who've been convicted of domestic
abuse i mean and
those background checks based on that
happen every day and they've saved
countless lives you know we're in the uh
in the in the hundreds of thousands of
of of
i think it might be more than that um of
guns that have been sailed i haven't
looked at the figures lately of sales
that have been prevented to those people
in the prohibited categories imagine how
many lives
that saved so
there's really people might want you to
think there's a there's a real struggle
and debate over how you would categorize
these people but the fact is they're
already you know why is the speed limit
55 instead of 57 you know at some point
it becomes an arbitrary conversation but
the important thing is that there is a
speed limit in place and it works and it
saves lives and so forth the problem is
that all the gun sales that happen in
our country
every day
that
are outside of
that background check system so that
background check system only happens at
federally licensed firearm dealers
and you know it's there's one happening
right now i guarantee it where somebody
is getting a background check and and
you know it'll be decided whether
they're in any of those categories or
not and they'll be able to be able to
get their gun the problem is you know
when you hear about and i think this is
language that isn't helpful things like
the gun show loophole
you know what the gun show have you
heard of the gun show loophole
no no the gun show loophole is what
people call the fact people on the gun
control side call the fact that
people can walk into a quote gun show
which is ambiguously
defined which is part part of the
problem
and
be
um and
buy a gun without a background check
because it's uh because it's a gun show
and it's not a federally licensed
firearm dealer sometimes from federally
licensed firearm dealers and do it off
the books
so that hurts the law-abiding
gun dealers because those people don't
have to charge taxes number number one
but it really hurts all of our
collective safety because if you're a
straw purchaser who wants to buy guns
and flood them into impacted communities
across the country you think you're
going to go to a federally licensed
firearm dealer to get those guns or do
you think you're going to go someplace
that does not require a background check
the reason why
i think it's very important to
[Music]
not just talk about it in terms of the
gun show loophole is that you know first
of all it's not true of all gun shows
but second of all it is true of any
place where guns are sold commercially
we're not talking about exchanging with
friends or and you know there are
conversations to be had in terms of
where that line is as well but you know
if i wanted to give a gun to my daughter
um i don't think she should have to go
through a background check you know and
so where where is that where is that
line but there are people who are
clearly engaged in the business of
buying and selling guns at all sorts of
venues online on websites that i don't
want to promote right now um at these
gun shows but the problem is if you turn
them down at a gun show they'll go
across they'll go on to the parking lot
they'll go across the street into the
parking lot of the gas station so there
needs to be a law
that and and this is what i think could
be the biggest improvement to the
current system there needs to be a law
that requires the commercial sale of
guns how we define it we can talk about
it requires the commercial sale of guns
to have a background to have background
checks and that law would have a
tremendous impact and it would
um go a long way toward accomplishing
again what we all want which is just to
be safer
so you're saying that at the moment
there's no law that asks for background
checks for commercial the commercial
sale of guns no well commercial sales at
federally licensed firearm dealers to
get your federal firearm license you
have to conduct a background check and
those background checks are conducted
thousands of times every day um the
problem is
you're some sort of prohibited per
you're a convicted violent felon who's
gotten out of jail you go into a gun
store you try to buy a gun
they
you have to fill out a form they do that
background check they say you know
you're a convicted violent felon you're
not allowed to have a gun
you walk out of that store you walk down
the street in most states
and many i'm not sure if it's most many
states and
uh you go to a quote gun show
and that you that same person can buy a
gun from a table or somebody walking
around
with with with the same gun that they
wanted
those people at the gun show i'm saying
the way to because some of those are you
know those grandfathers fathers and
their kids that i'm talking about and
hunting and let's go and look you know
i don't know if you went to like shows
like car shows gun shows whatever it is
you know there's hobbyists they're
people who are genuinely into it so i'm
not saying that and if i just sell one
gun to one person i'm not even
necessarily saying that that should be
the case but i'm saying if those people
go if people go to a gun show and are
selling
you know some threshold let's say you
know more than five guns every six
months if they're taking credit cards
for their transactions if they're
advertising that is a commercial sale
and so those commercial sales have to be
made the same as the commercial sale
that would have gone down at the
um
at the gun store had
that fictional person pass the
background check
okay so why isn't that in place already
because
people
misconstrue a lot of things and a lot of
the things we talked about um
people
misconstrue it as being a political
debate over gun rights people
look at it you'll sometimes hear the
slippery slope argument well first you
want to do this and then you want to
take my rights away then you have
organizations again i believe on both
sides of the issue
kind of
feeding
that emotional us versus them
conversation you know
there's so much language that's used
like you know the gun nuts the you know
it's like don't do that
these are people who want you know what
we want and so
um as unfortunately as a result there's
this it's it's become impossible to
change the political status quo because
it's so it's so entrenched so it's just
easy you know you can also say like why
did nothing happen after
you know insert horrific uh school
shooting here you know and that's a
that's a question you get a lot because
people have gotten good people who are
incentivized to maintain this as a
political debate have gotten good at
maintaining this as a political debate
and as a result the american public
isn't getting getting the real story on
this issue and they're
like look i'm you you've done your
homework and i'm talking to you and
you're like wait that's why isn't that
why isn't that the case um and it it
it's so
it is at the end of the day so simple
but that's testimony to how just
effing crazy this issue is in terms of
people you know making it into this
emotional political debate
interesting okay so what i've seen in
the news and what's been popularized is
the emotional debate where it's like
people shouldn't own guns period like
take everybody's guns
away because guns make the world more
dangerous that's the one side of the
story and then the other side is oh no
guns make the world safer because you
can protect yourself from the people who
shouldn't have guns who have guns
so that's i guess the politicized debate
that's been going on that's probably
like the most fundamental example of it
yes
and
the little secret is the reality is
both of those things are true
and so let's talk about it
yes
gun rights organizations
that you know aren't necessarily really
concerned about
the rights or certainly the well-being
of individual
gun owners yes
um
that got gun owning a gun presents a
risk when you bring a gun into your
house let's talk about it there is there
are scenarios where owning a gun is
unsafe why would you not want to educate
people about that scenario what you can
do to mitigate the danger that's not a
gun control conversation but that is
that's an education conversation but
it's a critically important conversation
at the same time
gun control community you know a
community that i helped to lead for a
number of
years um
there is a right
to own guns
you're not going to get anywhere by
trying to talk people out of that right
and trying to
and trying to say nobody should own guns
you're just going to perpetuate that
that polit that political debate and
even
there are scenarios where guns make you
safer
i mean i you know
i have a place way out in the sticks in
the country and
you know i know a lot of people
up there a lot of friends that i have
own guns and i get it and you know
you're there there could be animals
there could be
um
there there could be an intruder it may
legitimately take a long time for with
no local police department for the state
troopers to get there you know
is there a scenario where you can
legitimately be safer to have a gun this
is blasphemy to a lot of the people from
the community or that i used to that i
used to leave is there a scenario where
a gun can make you safer
yes
so let's have both of those it's not
cognitive dissonance let's have both of
those conversations at the same time
let's acknowledge there are real risks
let's talk about what we can do to
mitigate those risks and then let's
acknowledge that people who own guns
aren't all bad most of them aren't bad
most of them are good people who want
what we all want and our d and our
decent people so let's you know let's
acknowledge let's acknowledge that and
let's talk about the fact that there are
people who derive real benefit and value
um and fulfillment from owning guns
and let's
then that sets up the opportunity to
have this conversation about you know
things like background checks on all gun
sales things like educating gun owners
about um and it's not all gun sales by
the way but background checks things
about educating gun owners but right now
like you said what you see in the news
is just the people people don't dive as
deep as you're diving and don't look for
that common ground like you are so
there's like all right time to do a gun
control story queue up you know dan
gross and whoever the other person is
that you're going to talk to and it just
winds up kind of fitting into this mold
that at the end of the day needs to be
broken in order to do something about
this issue
yes i agree
okay so so some other questions i had
just out of curiosity do states that
have stricter gun control
do they have less gun violence in
general you know so that's
if you're talking to somebody who goes
and leans on that argument
chances are you're not talking to
somebody who either fully appreciates
this issue or is
worse
using numbers to
um
kind of undermine
making some sort of genuine progress
you can't just look at
state state by state laws because
you know it's it's a weakest link thing
if i'm in new york and new jersey has
incred that's it's not true new jersey
has good laws but um if new jersey has
incredibly weak laws i can just go right
over the border there are places on the
board and there are all sorts of
examples of this there's a whole
thriving gun industry on the border of
california and nevada because california
is strictly and so people who again
those people who might want to traffic
guns into impacted communities in
california they'll get in the car and
drive a few hours and go so you can't
say
that you know states with tougher gun
laws have
um
have no difference in
the amount of gun violence and and
present that as a
argument against anything that i just
said
you know until this point um
with what i would view as
positive intentions
that was a totally reasonable response
yes okay i've got a couple of other
questions to throw your way hit me i
feel like if you you've had practice
though years and years of practice
okay
other countries
are there other countries that have as
many guns as the states
but less crime
um
there's some debate about that i i will
say
but you know because part of it is and
again it's a it's a little bit of a red
herring in terms of the conversation
which is why these what you're asking me
are never things that i use to justify
any of the positions that that we talked
about before i can tell you there are
states with
some with significant percentage of gun
ownership like israel and you know where
everybody um up to uh you know has to
spend two years in the army um and uh
switzerland i understand has but
they
have
way stricter
laws in terms of background checks and
all the kind of things that i'm
advocating um you know and they're also
more respectful of the risks you know as
i understand in israel your service
weapon you know is either has to be or
encouraged to be
kept
someplace outside of outside of the home
so again it's not it's not the thing to
focus on when
you're trying to make the case for any
of the uh for the two things that i'm
advocating which are keep guns out of
the wrong hands and educate gun owners
about the risks and yeah there's a whole
industry and it's part of that industry
of people who
you will talk to um
hopefully not as part of this hopefully
you'll talk to somebody who's genuinely
um you know what well-intentioned in
terms of trying to make our country
safer but you know there are a lot of
people out there who
and a good test are the people who make
make those points because that in
response to the things that i'm
advocating because let me just be clear
there is no connection between either of
those two things
and anything that i said prior to this
that i know will make us all safer
okay so the argument perhaps the
argument where they're like look at this
country there are more guns there and
it's safer they're not taking into
consideration the fact that these people
are educated differently on guns
they're they're educated differently
they have different laws in terms of
who's able to get guns so ironically
some of those some of those countries
where that may rival the us i'm not sure
any place passes the us um but but you
know let's even say they do but at least
rival the u.s
um
you know they
they have much lower rates of gun
contr gun violence because they actually
have
the kind of
laws that that i'm talking about right
now in our country the problem is not
primarily
the number of guns
at this point the problem is the hands
that the guns are getting into whether
it's unsupervised children somebody with
suicidal ideation
um or a straw purchaser who's funneling
guns into the impacted communities
that's
those are the problems the problem is
not you know so it's again
that's used to kind of perpetuate this
political debate saying slippery slope
they just want to take all your guns
away and so it becomes very convenient
to say look at all these countries and
the gun
by the way all this and i'm just not
engaging on it the u.s does have
certainly
at least among the highest rates of gun
ownership and the correlation that you
see between the number of guns and
gun deaths is definitely on the side of
more guns results in more gun deaths
just like more cars will result in more
car deaths or more hammers will result
in in more hammer deaths but
i don't engage on that because the fact
is the fact there are
you know 300 million plus guns out there
in america we are not taking those guns
away it is counterproductive to argue
taking
you know take taking guns away from
anybody it's counterproductive because
it distracts from the real things that
we can do that the owners of those 300
million guns would listen to but aren't
currently listening to because they
think you're trying to take their their
their guns away
okay have there been laws implemented to
restrict
i'm going to make sure i get my
my words right but
um the guns that like that they're like
automatic you can shoot a whole bunch of
balls yeah so they're not those have
been restricted right yeah those have
been restricted the machine guns fully
automatic guns have been restricted very
heavily for a long time um
the debate is over what are called
assault weapons
um
and assault weapons like the ar-15 those
are semi-automatic um and then also as
part of that large capacity
uh magazines where you can just
so an automatic gun is where you hold
down the trigger and it just fires a
semi-automatic is where you have to pull
the trigger each time individually and
they have large capacity magazines and
you know and that's that's what the uh
the the debate is is over um and
believe it or not that's also a debate
that i think is not the right place
to
put
our emphasis
for
for for a variety
of
important reasons um let's just start
with
an important one but i don't think the
most important one which is
it's difficult to define
what an assault weapon is and where you
you know and where you draw the line and
people you know
do people use ar-15s for hunting
absolutely but what about target
shooting and is that you know so
that become and by the way my brother
was shot with a semi-automatic gun with
a high-capacity magazine so i'm not just
cavalierly saying this yeah you know if
that person didn't have that gun there's
a good chance my brother um you know
wouldn't have been shot or wouldn't have
been as previous but i'm just thinking
about this in terms of how to have the
biggest impact so there's a question in
terms of how to define what is an
assault weapon and that winds up being
you know uh a
you know that's a
tucker frickin carlson you know i went
on his show and did an interview and all
he wanted to talk about is like can you
define an assault weapon i'm like i'm
not here to talk about that i'm here to
talk about keeping the guns out of the
hands we all of the people he had no
interest in talking about that because
that's not what his viewers want to hear
and that's not how he gets get gets
rating so you know so i i like to first
kind of put put that aside um then
looking at it
pragmatically and again i'm
myself have had personal experience with
the very unpragmatic side of this
um
the percentage of
gun
deaths and injuries
even the percentage of mass shootings
even the percentage of school shootings
is
relatively
low in the case of the mass shootings
and just tiny in terms of the overall
toll of gun deaths in our country so
and and the word
you know assault weapon what you'll
usually hear is in the context of what
the gun control community says and the
gun
rights community likes to
um power it back assault weapons ban
we gotta ban these assault weapons
problem is it has the word ban in it it
makes it seem like we're coming for your
guns it gives people a ground to stand
on that's at least debatable in terms of
the second amendment it's my right to
own this gun well the second amendment
can be you're already in a place where
you've lost
kind of the emotional resonance of the
argument instead and this is why i go
back to what i said in the beginning
let's talk
not about how to keep
certain guns assault weapons in this
case
from everybody from all people let's
talk about how to keep every gun assault
weapons and otherwise from the people
who are most likely
and already defined as
most likely to harm already defined as
the most dangerous people so like a
background check i don't care whether
it's an ar-15 or a saturday night
special i care that a gun trafficker
convicted felon can't walk into a
you know a a gun show or go online or
meet somebody in a parking lot and and
buy it and buy it and buy
that gun
okay you mentioned earlier and this is
something i wasn't familiar with straw
purchaser
yeah um so straw purchaser is
somebody who
um
i'm not saying you ever did this but um
when one is
15 years old and
and they need to get a beer in 7-eleven
um
they uh
they said somebody in the parking lot to
go definitely done that buy the gun and
then and then sell them the beer and
give them the beer no no no judgment no
accusation but that person was a straw
purchaser what happens with with with
guns is
um people who
can pass background checks very often
when they're not getting it at places
that don't require background checks
will go and buy
you know dozens of guns
scores of guns
sometimes in another state
and bring them back and sell them
um
in the communities that are most
impacted by gun violence it goes back to
the question you say before well new
york you know chicago illinois chicago
chicago is the toughest gun laws and why
do they have so much gun violence a big
part of that is because of these straw
purchasers they'll buy the guns they're
middle people they'll buy the guns
they'll
i think the technical term would be like
a straw man straw woman whatever they
are mostly men um
purchaser who will um buy that gun and
then go and sell it and and make a
profit and they're just like ridiculous
examples of what happened so there's one
gun store right on the outskirts of
chicago called uh but over the chicago
city limit so this person can exist
there called chuck's gun shop and and
pistol range where
that is known
to sell a high percentage of the guns
that turn up on the streets of chicago
in
the
terrible toll of gun violence that
happens there you know seemingly on on a
daily basis and a big part of that is
because of these straw purchasers and
what chuck's is what i've always called
um a a bad apple gun dealer because
they're kind of spoiling it for everyone
else a tiny percentage of gun dealers
engage in that behavior where they are
knowingly selling guns
like you know sure i'll sell you these
20 guns and not ask a question because
you can pass this background check
knowingly selling guns that are winding
up on the streets and causing uh all all
this gun violence so another thing in
addition to crop cracking down on the
straw purchasers is also cracking down
on these unscrupulous
uh these unscrupulous gun dealers i mean
it's not it's like
the 80 20 rule on steroids like the 80
20 rule would be 20 of gun owners sell
80 of of uh crime guns it's more like
five percent of gun dealers sell 95 of
crime guns so if we can just do
something to go after these gun dealers
and crack down and straw purchasers that
to me has always been
one of the big opportunities to
affect gun violence in these communities
where and then so you can start to see
how
somebody who says well there's nothing
we can do in chicago in terms of gun
control so let's not have this
conversation because chicago already has
tough gun laws i just explained to you
how
yes chicago is very tough gun laws but
chuck's is not covered the straw
purchasers are
are not are not being dealt with and
that is the reason why they have that
gun violence
okay that's interesting so do you have
suggestions on how these straw purchases
would be cracked down on
yeah so one
one
aspect of it we've already talked about
which is
to make sure that everyone
has to who's engaged in the business
commercial the business of selling guns
has to do background checks
so
that so a straw purchaser can't walk
into
you know a gun show
um can't go online
and to to one of these websites that i
will not advertise
um and
buy
guns from strangers
without a background check and if we did
that that would have a very a very big
impact and i'll tell you the state fact
that is relevant is the states
with the
weakest laws in that regard are the
states that are the sources of most of
the crime guns
in new york and chicago and detroit and
the places that are um you know in a lot
of smaller places i don't mean to just
give the love all three of those cities
um you know but it's happening
everywhere and it's happening because
they call i-95 the firearm freeway
because the guns come up from the states
along the eastern seaboard that have
weak gun laws the southern states around
things like straw purchasers and
background checks and they're brought up
to you know newark i'll pick on someone
else or you know um other other places
on the eastern seaboard that might have
tougher gun laws so that's one thing
that we can do and then the other thing
that we can do
is
all out war on these unscrupulous gun
dealers who are doing this
knowingly throw real resources at it
because like the numbers are there again
five percent of gun gun dealers sell 95
percent of crime guns you know you want
to you you want to like really focus on
something bring the weight of the
government down on something you know
we have to leave no stone unturned in
terms of going after those gun dealers
that are literally knowingly supplying
guns onto the streets and by the way
giving a bad name to the 95 percent of
gun dealers that sell zero crime guns
okay so you could potentially identify
crime guns and then if a whole bunch of
them are coming from one place crack
down on that place and that's how you do
that and they have that info
they have that info yeah that info
exists that's weird yeah right
yeah that's that's why that that to me
has always been
the you know
possibly the biggest thing so when i get
not frustrated because there's a lot of
good conversation about
things like
you know
changing the so you know the
socioeconomics and the um systemic
racism and
um you know the uh
oppression of
you know people in these impacted
communities um and that's right that's a
conversation that has to be had
um and then there are great programs
like the violence interrupters that go
in and you know when it seems like
there's a
i don't want to like marginalize myself
by saying beef but or at one point that
was the
starting or there's been one shooting to
kind of come in and intervene in
somebody who might be a former gang
member and and and kind of bring people
together to prevent it from escalating
into more these are very very important
things i look him a look at it as tent
pulse um
the third temple that does not get
discussed
as prevalently as the other two but i
think as it relates to gun violence not
a whole host of other things that are
impacted by by by um all the by systemic
racism and and
and and other forms of oppression um you
know it's the it it doesn't get talked
about and it would have on gun violence
just as much of an impact if not more
um than than either of those two things
at least in the near future
yeah okay well i think i think that
summarizes your stance fairly well thank
you very much for coming on uh
is there anything else you want people
to know or any websites you want people
to go to or where people can find you
before we end this part of the segment
yeah um they can look me up at d gross
packs on uh on twitter um and uh yeah
we're the
organization that i'm starting with a
guy in the gun rights community very
prevalent uh activist in the gun rights
community is called the center for gun
rights and responsibilities so you can
just uh search that up and see the
latest in terms of what's going on there
and i want to thank you for
first of all your intention of bringing
that bringing people together and having
a good conversation and that is
consistent with certainly the way that i
i look at look at this issue and for
doing your research and being so
prepared for this conversation and for
yeah for letting me ramble and kind of
get my get my points across so thank you
michaela
well thank you
that was very informative thanks again
for coming on cool you have a good one
[Music]
dr john lott welcome to my podcast well
thanks for having me on good to talk to
you this should be a good conversation
uh before we get started could you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
my name is john lott i'm president of
the crime prevention research center
i have a phd in economics i have held
teaching and research professorships at
stanford university of chicago
the wharton business school yale
i was chief economist for the united
states sentencing commission
and then more recently
i was senior advisor for research and
statistics for the u.s department of
justice
so i've had both academic positions and
positions in the federal government to
deal with law enforcement type issues
okay and then before i start hammering
you with questions
what are your views on gun control at
the moment are there things that could
be improved
too many guns not enough guns can you
give a brief background about just how
you see gun control in america
well i think unfortunately a lot of the
gun control that we have right now
primarily disarms the very people who
need protection the most if my research
convinces me of anything
it's people who are most likely victims
of violent crime
overwhelmingly poor blacks who live in
high crime urban areas
who are the ones who benefit the most
from having the option to be able to go
and protect themselves the police are
very important but the police themselves
understand that they virtually always
arrive on the crime scene after the
crimes committed
and having a gun turns out to be by far
the safest course of action
unfortunately
a lot of the gun control laws that we
have
make it very costly for poor people and
discriminated against minorities so just
give you one example from when i was
just working in the federal government
and that is
you know we hear that the background
check system has stopped 3.8 million
prohibited people from be able to go and
obtain a gun
that's simply false what they should say
is that there have been 3.8 million
initial denials and over 99 of those are
mistakes
it's one thing to stop a felon from
buying a gun it's another thing to stop
somebody simply because they've been
named similar to a felon from being able
to go and buy a gun and the problem is
is that mistakes overwhelmingly
discriminate against black males and
hispanic males
the error rate for black males is more
than three times their share of the
population and for hispanic males it's
more than two and a half times their
share of the population and there's no
reason why we should have these mistakes
occurring
private companies do background checks
on employees all the time if they had an
error rate that was 100 the error rate
that the federal government has they'd
be sued out of existence
and yet
you know i think this is a very
reasonable fix why not make the federal
government have to meet the same
standards for doing background checks
that private companies have to meet but
gun control advocates will fight you
tooth and nail against that
and there are other issues too just look
at the costs
in in washington dc where they're voting
on this they have background checks on
the private transfers of guns it costs
125 dollars to do a background check on
on each gun that you're going to sell
let's say you and i lived in washington
dc
uh and i'm going to go and give you four
guns it's just one person
giving one other person four guns you're
thinking just be one background check
because you're the same person who's
getting all the guns right but no they
have it set up so that there has to be a
separate background check done on each
gun and so the total cost of making that
one transfer is five hundred dollars
provide me with a logical explanation
for why
they need to make it so incredibly
costly for people going by guns it may
not stop you or i from being able to go
and get a gun but again the very people
who need protection the most are being
priced out of this you know
democrats will go and say you know we
can't have uh uh
voter ids government issued photo ids
for for voting because that
imposes too large of a burden on poor
minorities well how does the 125 dollar
fee affected and that's not even the
cost of getting the id you have to have
a government-issued id in order to go
and buy a gun
and then they have other licensing rules
and other things that just make it very
costly i give you one other example and
that is
compare illinois and indiana okay uh
illinois a heavily democratic state
indiana heavily republican state in
indiana over 20 percent of the adult
population has a concealed carry permit
in illinois it's three percent
and and there's a simple reason for that
in illinois it costs about 450 dollars
to go through the process to get a
concealed carry permit in indiana
it's zero
you look at the distribution the only
types of people who go and get concealed
carry permits in illinois are
overwhelmingly white
wealthy males who live in the suburbs in
indiana uh it's much more poor blacks
and hispanics who live in high crime
urban areas who are then able to go and
afford to go and protect themselves and
you go down the list and in
in chicago up until very recently they
banned any training facilities for
getting a concealed carry permit
so you're a poor black
there they require 16 hours of training
you know if you don't have a car
you have to go and borrow a car either
two or four days because of 16-hour
training that's there they don't allow
you to take even a permanent concealed
handgun on public transportation so what
does that do it makes it it's like they
went through the list 450 cost unable to
take it on public transportation uh no
training facilities allowed nearby you
it's kind of like they went down a
checklist to do everything they possibly
can to make sure that the very people
who need protection the most are the
ones who are not able to do it
and i i'll give you one last example
there's two types two main types of
concealed carry laws in the united
states they're what we call right to
carry laws
which
42 of the states have which once you
meet certain criteria you're allowed to
carry you know you pay a fee you pass a
background check you do your training
and then there are eight states like new
york and california where you have to
provide a good reason to some public
official why they should let you be able
to go and have an option to carry a
concealed handgun so
take los angeles county okay where i was
able to get a list of everybody who had
gotten approved for getting a concealed
handgun permit
they only had like
216 concealed carry permits out of an
adult population of 8 million people
but who do they give who do they decide
has a good reason nationwide about a
third of concealed carry permit holders
are women in los angeles county it's
seven percent
nationwide thirteen percent of concealed
care permit holders are black in los
angeles county it's five percent
54
of los angeles county's population is
hispanic only six percent of the permit
holders are hispanic
you know you think
are women only stalked in the rest of
the country and not being stalked in los
angeles county don't they have good
reasons that are given there and yet the
public officials there
who are who are overwhelmingly 100
democrat don't seem to the only people
that they think provide them with good
reasons to be able to carry are
basically wealthy politically connected
white males overwhelmingly are the ones
that they decide have good reasons why
is it
they say they care about poor and
minorities they say they care about
women but yet they don't seem to trust
those very same people when they're
asking for permission to be able to go
and defend themselves and their families
okay so
how should the government regulate guns
like for these background checks how do
they decide who should have access to a
gun and who shouldn't
well i mean you can go and have it so
that people who have felony backgrounds
violent felony backgrounds in particular
can be stopped from being able to go and
get guts
i'm no problem with that my point is
simply if you're going to have these
make it so the system works have
reasonable fixes to the background check
system you know
otherwise you're you're
you're making it so that the very people
who need protection the most are being
priced out of being able to do it and
having mistakes
look you can go and appeal when the
federal government makes a mistake but
virtually everybody's going to require a
lawyer to help them go through the
process fix the thing
the starting cost for hiring a lawyer is
like three thousand dollars on up okay
why should somebody through no fault of
their own simply because the federal
government's looking at roughly
phonetically similar names and similar
birthdays and doing background checks
why should they have to pay
thousand dollars or more to fix a
mistake that's not their fault
so you're saying
keep the background checks but fix the
inconsistencies
right but here's the problem and that
exactly but here's the problem i've been
making this argument for 20 years but
democrats will fight you tooth and nail
against a simple fix i want somebody to
explain to me what reasonable
explanation can you give for why 99
of the people who are stopped from
buying guns because of background checks
are mistakes
give me give me an explanation for why
you'd want a system where virtually
everybody who gets stopped is not the
guy you think you're stopping
seems reasonable
so
how easy though for people who get
stopped with background checks how easy
is it for them to go to say a gun show
and then get a gun there
i mean the vast majority of guns
anybody who's a licensed dealer who's
selling a gun any place has to go and do
a background check i don't know if
you've ever been
to a gun show but virtually everybody
who's selling a gun there is a licensed
dealer and they have to go through and
do a background check that's there look
we the federal government or i've been
has done surveys of criminals to find
out where they go and get their guns
you're talking about maybe
less than one percent maybe six tenths
of one percent of felons get their guns
from either gun shows or flea markets
this is not a major source of guns but
if you're
where do you think the major source of
guns for for criminals are it's drug
deals
drug dealers have guns simply because
they have to go and protect their
valuable property that they have it's
not like a drug dealer can go to the
police and say this other dealer stole
my drugs can you help us get them back
all right
they have to go and set up essentially
their own little militaries in order to
go and protect that valuable property
that they have
so you know drug dealers like to make
money and if they can make money selling
drugs they do that if they can make
money selling guns they do that too
and you know uh it's
if you think you're going to be able to
stop
criminals from buying guns any more
easily then you can stop them from
buying illegal drugs good luck with that
i mean i give talks at universities i go
and ask students you know if i give them
a few days how many of them can go and
buy different types of illegal drugs and
i'm not saying they do this but you have
maybe 80 percent of the students raise
their hands to think that there's no
problem that they're going to be able to
do it
these drug dealers have very valuable
property you know you look at a country
like mexico okay next door to us there
um mexico since 1972 has had only one
gun store in the country
it's located in mexico city it's run by
the military guns are extremely
expensive the most powerful gun that
you've been able to legally buy in
mexico since 1972 is a 22 caliber short
round rifle which is about the least
powerful gun that you can go and buy in
the united states and
you know
um
only
only about one tenth of one percent of
mexican adults is legally licensed to
own a gun
it costs like two thousand dollar fee
just to go and apply for the process to
go and get a get a gun to own in your
home
in mexico uh you can't sell it to
anybody even if you do get a gun you
want people you can sell it back to is
the federal government
so you think boy they have incredibly
strict gun control laws and yet mexico
has a murder rate six times higher than
the murder rate that we have in the
united states
drug dealers in mexico bring in
drugs from around the rest of the world
and they go and bring in weapons from
around the world
when i was recently testifying a few
years ago in mexico before the federal
senate and house
you know it's amazing you go talk to law
enforcement there they had found
something like 15 000 hand grenades that
they had confiscated from uh
drug gangs down there do you think you'd
go to american uh gun stores and buy
hand grenades
they had confiscated machine guns do you
think you'd go to gun stores in the
united states and buy machine guns no
these are weapons some of them they
stole from the mexican military but lots
of them they brought they brought in
from around the world south america and
asia and other places like that
and
you know they have rocket launchers they
have all sorts of other things because
there's a huge amount of money involved
in drug smuggling that's there and so it
pays for them to go and buy weapons to
protect themselves not just from the
government but also from other drug
gangs that will try to steal their
valuable property that's there if i
could click my fingers
right now and cause all
guns in the united states to disappear
and all illegal drugs how long do you
think it would be before illegal drugs
started coming back into the united
states
if you're in el paso 20 minutes
and how long before they'd go and bring
in the illegal guns to go and protect
that valuable property
they'd bring them in at the same time
they're not going to risk bringing in
huge amounts of very valuable property
that could be stolen from them and they
want to protect them
and so
you know the notion that somehow
you know you're going to be any more
successful in stopping criminals from
getting guns than you've been from
stopping them from getting illegal drugs
i just don't think is very serious and
what people have to realize is what a
huge percentage of murders in the united
states are drug gang related
over half the murders in the united
states occur within two percent of the
counts at 60 of the
3140 counties in the united states
account for over half the murders
and if you look at what's called a
murder map
of those counties what you'll find is
almost two-thirds of their murders take
place within 10 block areas
murders unlike most other countries
murders in the united states are
extremely heavily concentrated in very
tiny areas within the united states you
have you have three quarters of the
counties in the united states that have
either zero murders or one murder in a
year
about 60 percent have zero murders in
any given year
you know
by the way those are the counties that
tend to have the highest gun ownership
rates in the united states
but
you know in any case uh
if you're going to deal with the murder
problem in the united states you're
going to have to go and deal with drug
things and that's a conversation i'm
happy to have but uh i just mentioned
one other thing and that is
people have to realize that the vast
majority of violent crime in the united
states also doesn't involve guns 92
percent of violent crime in the united
states has no connection with guns in
any way
so if you're going to go and solve
violent crime you have to go and deal
with violent crime general but if you're
going to deal with murders
you're going to have to go and deal with
drug deaths because they fight against
each other all the time to try to
control drug terms
i've heard that and i could be wrong but
i've heard that a lot of the
guns used in crime in the states are
bought through straw purchases
purchasers
is that true
look
one i don't believe that that's the case
you look at surveys of people who are in
prison that's not the case they buy them
off the street they buy them from others
that are there but here here's the
problem and that is
they're close substitute ways for though
them to go and get guts you know just as
the discussion we were just having
you know if i could go and cause all
guns to disappear from the united states
do you think
do you think new guns will be brought in
to protect the drug gangs that are there
and if you think that that definitely
yeah okay so if you think that that's
the case
then
you know even if you stop one way even
if that was a significant way of doing
it there are other ways that they're
going to go and get the weapons that
they need to protect their valuable
property
okay
so
you're suggesting well we keep the
background checks but that
it has to be fixed so that it's not
randomly choosing people with similar
names to
people who have caused violent crimes
right similar names and similar
birthdays i mean
i don't know if you've ever bought a gun
but you fill out something called a 4473
you put down your name your address your
social security number your birthday
your race your eye color
you think they're using all that
information but they're not they're the
vast majority of checks just look at
roughly phonetically similar names and
similar birthdays
and there's no reason why that should be
the case
unfortunately i've come to the
conclusion
that
the people who are pushing these
background checks really don't care
about the background checks because they
could get them past tomorrow or today if
they just made a few
really simple changes make it so that uh
the the federal government has to meet
the same standards for doing background
checks that private companies do
pay for the checks out of general
revenue so here here's the general point
if you believe
that background checks reduce violent
crime then you believe it reduces it for
everybody not just the person who's
going out of the way to go and obey the
law that's there and also you think you
want to encourage people to go and obey
the law how does making somebody have to
pay 125 dollars to go and do the
background check encourage them to go
and do that
you're essentially taxing them to go and
do what you want them to do yeah
way to do that
so as an economist i would say look if
everybody benefits everybody should pay
and if you want to encourage people to
do this
both reasons tell me you should pay for
it out of general revenue if you could
make those two changes fix the mistakes
and me and deal with paying for it out
of general revenue if you think they're
these big benefits and i i'm skeptical
there are but if you think there are
these big benefits you think they'd want
to do that and yet and i've been telling
them for 20 years they could get this
passed right away but they refuse to
make those changes and to me i have to
ask myself
what are the arguments against these
things the only arguments that i can
think of against these things is that
they want to make it costly
they want to make it difficult they want
to prevent poor minorities from being
able to go and buy guts if you have
another explanation
in fact
when we were setting this up i was
hoping
that we could have
the gun control person on at the same
time so that they could say what their
explanation is for something like this
because i never hear an explanation when
i go and i bring up these concerns
yeah well those are fair questions
those are fair questions i may set these
up in the future so that i have both
people on it once but for now it's
interesting i'm not criticizing each
other
i'm just saying
i really want it's very hard to get
debates on these types of things because
gun control activists refuse to appear
on at the same time and the main reason
is is because
they don't have to most the media
doesn't make them have to go into
debates
do you think that people pushing that
are just concerned with maybe kind of
punishing people who want to own guns
and saying okay you have to do these
fees and we're not footing it and
they're not even considering the fact
that some people have less money
i think i think that's right i think
they're trying to make it as costly as
possible for people to be able to go and
get guns i'll give you another related
example
and that is uh look at these red flag
laws that they have uh they're being
pushed in fact
it looks like right now the federal
government's likely to
uh be using a lot of money to encourage
states to adopt these laws in the
current 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill that they have what are the laws
well these these are laws uh that are
set up so that if you're concerned about
somebody being a danger to themselves or
others you can go and register a
complaint a judge will see a piece of
paper with the complaint and then
they'll go and take away the person's
gun that's there for some period of time
maybe a month and then there'll be a
hearing whether or not to make it
permanent or not yikes okay uh so here's
the deal
we already have in all the states and it
goes by different names often called
baker act california is called 5150
where if you're concerned somebody's a
danger to themselves or others you go to
the police the person will undergo a 24
hour to 72 hour psychiatric evaluation
where you'll have psychiatric experts
there and then you'll have immediately
following that a hearing where
if you can't afford it a lawyer will be
provided for you okay and the judge has
a whole range of options there he can go
and require that you get voluntary
treatment
uh he can go and take away your weapons
if he's concerned about that or he can
go in the most extreme case and
involuntarily commit somebody
virtually always all these things are
used for concerns about suicide that's
yes
the thing is the red flag laws don't
involve mental health care experts okay
uh if you can't afford a lawyer tough
you know you have to
you go in on your own in fact you look
at these
cases in the red flag law
uh
it costs about ten thousand dollars to
go and do a hearing the only thing that
happens under the red flag laws is that
you lose your ability to have a gun well
i may want to have a gun i may care
about it for protection but ten thousand
dollars i mean ten thousand dollars is a
lot of money there and so the vast
majority of people who go through that
process
uh
don't get a lawyer when they have to go
to court uh and it makes it pretty hard
when you're up against lawyers and you
don't have a lawyer yourself
representing you uh to be able to go and
win those types of cases but it's it's
not because the people think that
they're really a danger or whatever it's
just that they don't even if they can't
afford it but here's the problem
is that
the type of change that they want to
make can actually have the opposite
effect of what they'd like to have what
they claim they want to have happen i
have a very close friend of mine uh
who's
watched her husband be murdered in front
of her by one of her stalkers
and
if you have these types of red flag laws
that are there let's say a friend of
hers a relative neighbor they say look
she's really depressed okay
i mean anybody would be you've just had
your loved one watched your loved one
murdered in front of you by one of your
stalkers that are there
and they know that she has a gun
and so they could go and say look i'm
worried she's depressed i'm going to she
has a gun
i'll make a complaint the only thing the
judge sees when he makes the decision
whether or not to take away the person's
gun is that written complaint
well in her case
if you put yourself in that situation
you've just had one of your stalkers
murdered your husband
how do you think you'd feel if your
ability to go and protect yourself was
going to be taken away from do you think
that'd make you even more depressed and
what does that do
to your incentive to go and talk to
people to share your feelings with
others if you worry that somebody might
misinterpret it
simply being able to go and talk to
people it's very helpful when you're
increasing extremely depressed like that
just being able to share your feelings
know that you're not alone can make a
huge difference in terms of how people
get through this type of thing
and yet the gun control advocates have
set up a process in
18 states now where
simply could be a very well meeting
person puts in a complaint judge hears
nothing from the person who's
the complaint is being launched against
and you know he may be well-meaning
himself he sees this person's depressed
they have a gun
yeah
but if you have
the process that we've had these baker
egg type things she could go in there
she gets evaluated by a psychiatric
expert she can explain to the expert why
it's important that she still be able to
go and defend herself and even if she
couldn't convince that person she goes
to court and if she can't afford a
lawyer one is provided for her and she
can make an argument to the judge so you
have to ask yourself
why did gun control advocates push a
situation where it would make people
actually afraid to go and talk to people
you take police officers police officers
tend to commit suicide at a relatively
high rate compared to the general
population they tend to be depressed at
a relatively high rate compared to the
rest of the population
why i mean they see horrible things on
the job all the time
do we want to make it so police officers
are afraid to go and share their
feelings with other people if you take
away a police officer's gun what do you
think you do to their job
you've taken away their job
that's there they lose their job if you
take away their guns
do we want to make it so the police
officers are afraid to go and talk to
people and yet
again i think these are simple
reasonable changes okay
pay for a lawyer if a person can't
afford it
make them include mental health care
experts in the process and have mental
health care experts evaluate the person
before you go and you have a hearing
don't have the the judge simply making a
decision based only on seeing the
written complaint and not being able to
hear the other person's side of the
story when he's making that type of
decision that's there
you know and besides if i'm really
concerned about somebody committing
suicide really concerned is the only
solution to take away their gun is there
like no other way for these people to go
and kill themselves
i mean go talk to jeffrey epstein if you
don't think that there's other ways for
people to go in and kill themselves uh
and so
you know it's
i think a lot of this is just to
demonize the gun it's just to say well
if you take away the guns situation
stalk there's no problem at that point
and i think that's really
dangerous i think that's really
misleading for people and i think
there's evidence out there that in fact
you increase suicide rates
and i think for the reason that i was
just mentioning that you make it so that
people now are afraid to go and share
their feelings and talk to other
people what do you think of people who
think that
there needs to be more education
surrounding how you store guns and
safety with guns and that that's one of
the problems with american gun control
at the moment it's just lack of
education
i have no problem with people being
educated about it but here's the thing
i think if you look at the numbers
americans are extremely responsible with
regard to guns
you can go to the centers for disease
control website uh their uh fatal injury
report data that they have and what
you'll find for let's say kids under age
10 in
the united states uh for the most recent
year there was 36 accidental gun deaths
in the united states is 36 do you wish
it was zero yeah sure i wish it was zero
but when you consider half of american
homes have guns
okay um
and you go and you look at anything else
when you have like 95 kids under five
who'd grounded in uh in five gallon
water buckets
you have uh more than that who drowned
in bathtubs in the home
so if i were to go and just ask you
beforehand and say okay
guns are owned in half of american homes
what is your guess
that children under age 10 died from
accidental gunshots my guess is your
number would have been much higher than
30. yeah
and part of the reason is is whenever
these things happen they get national
news coverage and it makes people think
that they're more common than they are i
think to some extent but
you know uh
and even when you look at those 36
uh
about two-thirds of those
are not shots by other children they're
shots by adult males usually in their
mid to late 20s who have criminal
records
who have in many cases it's illegal for
them to own guns and are often drug
addicts or alcoholics so you know i can
go and say we want to educate people but
a lot of these guys it's illegal for
them to own the gun to begin with and so
if i go and pass a gun lock wall is it
going to affect these guys
and a gun lock's not going to affect an
adult male particularly an adult male
criminal who's unlikely to go and obey
the law to begin with to be able to go
uh and do it it's not gonna stop him
from accidentally firing his gun
but here's the problem and that is
their costs and benefits i mean as an
economist we're always weighing
trade-offs with different things
and so
i go and pass a law that requires people
have to lock up their guns in their
homes okay which is one of the things
that's involved with this
it doesn't make sense for everybody to
do it if i live in a high crime urban
area i may want to have quick access to
a gun that's there delaying it may make
it so that i'm not able to know and
defend myself and my family you have to
weigh
the risks of the gun in the home versus
the fact that people aren't going to be
able to go and defend themselves and
often when these laws get passed you'll
see about a five percentage point drop
in gun ownership that occurs right when
these safe storage laws get passed and a
lot of that has to do with the
exaggerated stories that occur in the
media at that time about the dangers of
having guns in the home
and so look i mean i have five kids i
don't want anything to happen to any of
my kids but
i would go and argue that the vast
majority of americans are extremely
careful but the risk of a child dying
from an axe no gunshot in the home is
less than the risk of them dying from
lightning strikes do i go and tell my
kids not to go in an open field with an
umbrella when it's lightning outside
yeah sure there's sensible things you
try to go and do i would just argue i
think looking at the data that the vast
majority of americans are actually
behaving fairly responsibly and that
unfortunately this gets back to your
point before about whether a lot of
these laws are just trying to make it
cost
for people to be able to go and own guns
and i think this is just another example
of it they try
in many different ways to do that
okay last question
do do states that have stricter gun laws
does that reduce gun crime
no it has the opposite effect
let me give you just a simple example
just to think about this is an extreme
case but it applies generally and that
is can you name me one place in the
world that's banned either all guns or
all handguns and seeing murder or
homicide rates go down just one place
i'm talking about before and after
because there's all sorts of reasons why
different places differ uh in terms of
crime rates uh
it i can't find a single place every
single time
murder rates go up you think out of
randomness once or twice it would go out
uh you think particularly if you believe
guns on net are bad you would think for
sure it should go down every single time
and yet every single time you know
americans know about what happened in
chicago
and washington dc when we had handgun
bans there and the murder rates went up
gun control advocates will go will say
well that really wasn't a fair test
because unless you go and you ban guns
every place uh people can still go and
get guns from maryland or virginia or
from the west illinois or from indiana
the problem is that doesn't explain why
the murder rates went up it may explain
why it didn't fall as much as they were
originally predicting it was going to do
but they were able to get the guns from
those other places to begin with before
the ban went into effect
and so
but here's the problem and that is
and this applies to gun control laws
general
and that is you have to be careful when
you pass a law that you're not going to
be primarily disarming law-abiding
citizens relatives criminals you may
take some guns away from criminals but
if it's mainly in this case law-abiding
citizens turning in their guns obeying
the laws so you're primarily disarming
the victims relative to the criminals
you actually can make it easier for
criminals to go and commit crimes
and so you see increases
and so this applies to any of these
things the background check discussion
that we were having if it primarily
because of these mistakes and these
costs and other things primarily disarms
law-abiding citizens relative to
criminals you can actually have the
opposite effect of what you'd like to
have happen in these cases
and so
you know um
you know i i think if you look at the
serious statistical work i've been an
academic i've published over 120
peer-reviewed articles in journals uh
i think if you look at the serious work
to answer your specific question you
find that the states that have stricter
gun control laws tend to have uh higher
murder rates higher violent crime rates
and you know it's not just that you look
at concealed carry laws there's a huge
difference in across states in terms of
the percentage of the adult population
with concealed handgun permits uh
there as i mentioned there's basically
these two types of states these right to
carry states and these uh may issue
states in the main issue states you're
talking about literally of just a couple
few percentage points tenths of a
percentage point of the adult population
with a permit on average for the rest of
the states you're talking about nine
percent or so of the adult population
with permits uh and that was last year
my guess is it's probably about 10 right
now
and so
you know uh and
anyway but what you find is that those
states that make it easier for people to
go and get concealed handgun permits
particularly those states that make it
easiest for poor and minority people the
people who are most likely victims of
violent crime to be able to go and
defend themselves they have
the the biggest drops in violent crimes
as more permits are issued you see
greater drops in violent crime there's a
reason why police strongly support
concealed carry laws you look at surveys
of police officers you'll find like 95
percent of police in a survey by police
one which is about 450 000 members 380
000 of them are full-time law
enforcement the other 70 000 are retired
support relatively easy access to
concealed handgun permits for people
uh you know they see the importance in
their own lives of being able to go and
use a gun and they're strongly
supportive of private citizens being
able to do it uh
you know you look at another survey from
them where they asked them how important
is it for reducing crime for law-abiding
citizens to have guns 76 percent of
police officers think that private
ownership of guns is either extremely
important or very important in terms of
reducing crime
okay
that's a lot
so you know these are the
people that have to deal with these
situations all the time and then
so okay
well
i think that that settles it for me i
think i'm good i've asked you the
questions i wanted to ask you thank you
very much for coming on if you want to
direct people to either follow you
online or at any websites they should
know about
where do they go
well our our website is
crimeresearch.org crimeresearch.org
we're basically a group of academics as
i mentioned i've had positions at a
number of universities but we have
arthur berg at harvard
bill landis at the university of chicago
uh scott armstrong at the wharton
business school others who have
expertise in different areas uh you know
we know where the data is and that's
what we try to put out regularly there
so the people
if they go to crimeresearch.org they can
sign up for our email list uh once every
two weeks we send out an email so that
people can see the latest research that
we've been doing on these different
topics
very cool okay well thank you very much
for coming on
i appreciate your time thank you for
being here
[Music]
you